- Yeah, so for today's Data
For The People session,
we're gonna be discussing
a paper that goes into
the intersections of COVID-19
and type 2 diabetes.
So just before I start
talking about the paper,
I just wanna go into a quick outline of
what I'll be discussing
throughout this talk.
So first, I'll talk a
bit about what exactly
we're discussing and why
this is relevant to us,
and exactly why the authors decided
to research this specific topic.
Second, I'll be going into
some general definitions of
what exactly diabetes is, and
then what a comorbidity is,
and then what a significance test is,
which is something that's used
really throughout the study.
Next, I'll be talking about how exactly
the author's approach this issue,
so what techniques they utilize.
Ad then I'll talk a bit about
what exactly the authors add
to the field by a discussion of the data
that the authors present in this paper.
Lastly, I'll discuss some
conclusions made by the authors.
And in this discussion,
I'll also talk about
the clinical significance
of the authors' findings,
as well as some limitations
in future studies
of this research.
Okay, but before I go into all that,
I wanna talk a bit about myself.
So I was born in Moscow, Russia,
and I moved to the United
States when I was quite little,
I moved to Atlanta, Georgia,
and have lived in the
United States ever since.
So this is me,
I graduated from American University,
I got my undergraduate degree there
in physics and mathematics.
And I'm currently attending
Weill Cornell Medicine,
where I'm studying biophysics for a PhD.
And recently, I've really been into
just exploring New York City.
So this is me right in front
of the New York City Skyline,
and this is on the East
River in Williamsburg.
And I'm also really
been into vegan cooking.
So here's kind of a blueberry loaf,
that's vegan that I made
recently, and also this is like
a really cool vegan Korean
dish that I prepared recently.
Okay, so first, let's talk a bit about
what this paper is about
and why it's important.
So this is the paper
that we'll be discussing
throughout the talk.
The title is the Association
of Blood Glucose Control
and Outcomes in Patients with COVID-19
and Pre-existing Type 2 Diabetes.
So this paper is what is known as
a clinical and translational
report, which just means
that it is typically done on
human participants and it's
more so directed to direct
health outcomes in the project.
And lastly, this paper is published
in a journal called Cell Metabolism.
And that means that this
paper is fully peer reviewed.
And that just means that it
has gone through a process
where other scientists
in the field have gone
over this paper and have decided
that it is rigorous enough
to be published as a scientific journal.
Sorry, scientific article, excuse me.
Okay, so now I kind of wanna
go more so into what clinical
and translational research is,
as compared to what we call
basic science research.
So first, basic science
research is a more fundamental
and foundational research
that typically is designed
to kind of pave the way for
more applied science and medicine.
And this typically involves
reducing particular problems
to really their simplest terms,
and then using model systems
in order to tackle those problems.
So think of using different
kinds of cell types,
animal models, so you can
think of using like lab mice,
for different kinds of experiments.
And then sometimes computer
simulations are also used.
And then clinical and
translational research
is more so research that takes
from basic science research
and then applies that to
medical projects specifically.
So it's more so designed to
impact health outcomes directly.
And in the case of clinical research,
it typically involves human participants.
And the kind of research
that we're gonna be discussing today
is clinical and translational.
So these two being both,
like really rigorous kinds of research
are very similar in many aspects.
So both kind of utilize very
similar scientific research
and principles, as well as
pretty much the same kinds
of like research methodologies.
And they both involve like
really rigorous collaboration
between different kinds of specialists,
especially in the field of
medicine, both kinds of research
really incorporate
specialists from both fields.
And ultimately, they share the same goal,
which is the advancement of
knowledge, and in the field
of medicine, of course, the
improvement of health outcomes.
Okay, so going back to the paper a bit,
I kind of just wanted
to dissect this title.
So again, it's the Association
of Blood Glucose Control
and Outcomes of Patients with COVID-19
and Pre-existing Type 2 Diabetes.
So what this title is
basically saying is that
it's presenting research
about the outcomes in patients
that have type 2 diabetes
that contract COVID-19.
And this word "association"
just means that the authors
are attempting to do
and compare two groups
and find some sort of
correlation between them.
In this case, those those
things being COVID-19
and type 2 diabetes.
But when scientists want
to establish correlations,
the style of scientific reasoning that
they're typically using is
called probabilistic reasoning.
And this is just the use
of statistical methods
in order to establish regularities,
as well as identify
patterns within data trends,
and then establish
significance in those trends.
So when scientists use statistical, sorry,
probabilistic reasoning, again,
they're using statistical analysis
for particular data sets that they have
in order to establish significance
in those data trends in a rigorous way.
Okay, so now I'm just gonna discuss a bit
about why this research is important
and why these researchers
published their study.
So first, diabetes is a really
a major non-communicable
disease worldwide.
And actually, many
scientists have called it
a pandemic of itself.
So kind of understanding
diabetes in the context of COVID-19
is really important given
its really widespread nature
and how quickly it's been
spreading throughout the world.
Second, so diabetes is known to present
a really steep decline
actually in survivability
when it's combined with
respiratory illnesses.
So, it's already been known
that diabetes is kind of
a really major pre-existing
condition for a lot of diseases,
especially respiratory illnesses.
And actually, a really similar study
to this one had already been done
with diabetes and the SARS epidemic,
which took place in 2003
in East Asia, as well
as throughout the world.
So the authors of this
paper really wanna show
the same result rigorously for COVID-19.
And lastly, diabetes is known
to affect certain populations
really disproportionately,
as was previously mentioned.
And this really represents a
really serious public health
and a social challenge,
when we consider COVID-19,
just because of its extremely
widespread nature and
how quickly it spreads, and also the fact
that COVID-19 itself
also affects certain populations
really disproportionately.
So studying the interactions
of these two diseases
is really important for
improving the health outcomes
of these communities
where these diseases have
such a disproportionate effect.
Okay, so now I'm gonna
go into some definitions.
So I'll kind of define what diabetes is
and then talk about
what comorbidities are.
And then lastly, I'll go
into significance testing,
which is a technique that is
used all throughout the study.
And here are just some
keywords to keep track of
while I'm talking about some definitions.
So, the first is glucose.
Second is comorbidity.
And then the third is a significance test
as well as P-value, which is
part of significance testing.
Okay, so what is diabetes?
So a really general
definition of diabetes is that
it is a metabolic disorder
where the body's ability
to process glucose is disrupted.
And I've kind of highlighted
these two really key terms
here, metabolic and glucose.
And what metabolic means
is it pretty much refers
to any process that is kind
of biochemical in the body
which serves to sustain life in the body.
And then glucose is just
a small sugar molecule
which gives energy to your cells.
So kind of using those two definitions.
Diabetes is a disorder where
the life sustaining processes
that relates to glucose
processes in your body
are somehow disrupted.
Okay, so now to better
illustrate on diabetes,
I'm just gonna talk about what
metabolism kind of looks like
in someone that is a non-diabetic.
So, here's me.
So let's say that one day
I decide to eat a pizza.
So as I eat this pizza,
it'll travel down my body
into my digestive system,
and it'll be broken down
into several different components,
some of which are
carbohydrates, proteins, fats,
and several other nutrients
which I need to sustain my metabolism.
And so the one of these that's
really the most relevant
to our discussion today are carbohydrates,
which you can really think of as molecules
which kind of give your body
sort of like instant energy
after you eat food.
So once this pizza is broken
down into these carbohydrates,
the way that your body
can utilize the energy
from these carbs is by
breaking them further down
into the glucose molecules
that I talked about before.
And again, glucose is just
a small sugar molecule
that your body can use for energy.
Okay, so once this process happens,
the glucose kind of floats around
throughout your body in your blood,
and it's just kind of
waiting to be absorbed
by your cells so that they
can use them for energy.
But the problem is,
glucose actually can't be
directly absorbed by cells.
The glucose can't penetrate
the cell right away.
So what the body does is it utilizes
a specialized organ called the pancreas.
And what the pancreas does
is it can basically sense
when there's a lot of glucose in the body
after you just ate a meal, for example.
And then it releases a
hormone called insulin.
So once insulin is
released into your body,
it attaches to your cells,
and what happens is it acts kind of like
a key to like a locked door.
And then once this
happens, the glucose can
then absorb into the
cell and give it energy.
So what happens in the case
of a person that has diabetes?
So one of two things, or
actually both, can happen
in the case of diabetes.
The first is called insulin resistance.
And essentially what this is,
is even when insulin is
released into your body
and attaches to your cells,
the glucose that's floating in
your blood, it still
can't enter into yourself.
And then what happens is, your cells
basically can't get energy from glucose
and then the glucose starts
to accumulate in your blood.
The second thing is insulin misproduction.
And this basically happens
as a result of some damage
that comes from somewhere to the pancreas
and then it's basically unable
to produce enough insulin
basically, to meet the
demands of glucose absorption
for your body.
Okay, so when a person has diabetes,
and they develop insulin resistance
and insulin misproduction,
what can happen is, since your cells
basically aren't absorbing the glucose
that you get from eating in your body,
the glucose starts to
accumulate in your blood,
and this can really cause a
lot of damage to blood vessels.
Then, again, since the cells
aren't absorbing enough glucose,
they may not have enough energy
to kind of do the typical processes
that they would typically be doing.
And over time, this can cause damage
to a lot of organs throughout your body
and eventually cause
disease to those organs
and the most common as a result of
your cells not absorbing enough glucose
are kidney, liver and heart disease.
And all of these issues
given enough time can lead
to nerve degradation, excuse me,
which it itself can cause
a plethora of issues given enough time.
Okay, so, the last thing I wanna mention
about diabetes is that
there are two main types.
So the first type, usually
called type 1 diabetes,
is one that typically comes about
as a result of genetics.
And it's typically a result of some issue
in the cells of the pancreas
which produce insulin.
And this type of diabetes
accounts for approximately 5-10%
of all diabetes cases.
Okay, the second type of diabetes
is usually called type 2 diabetes.
And this type of diabetes
can really result
from a plethora of causes.
Poor diet can be a factor,
damage the pancreas can be a cause,
as well as genetics as well.
And this type of diabetes
is commonly called adult onset diabetes,
because it usually manifests in adults.
And this accounts for approximately 90-95%
of all diabetes cases, and
is the type of diabetes
that we'll be discussing
for the rest of this talk.
Okay, so now I really wanna
define what a comorbidity is.
And this is basically just any condition
whose symptoms can overlap
and potentially exasperate
the symptoms of another condition.
So, a pretty easy example, to think about
when thinking about comorbidities
is maybe imagine someone
that's suffering from asthma.
So they have symptoms,
which may cause them to
have trouble breathing.
And then let's say that they
contract respiratory illness
like the cold or flu.
So the symptoms of that
respiratory illness could
potentially exasperate
the pre-existing asthma
that this person has.
And as you can imagine,
breathing can become
much more difficult for them.
So we would say that asthma
has been a comorbidity
for that respiratory illness.
So here, I'm just kind of
illustrating potential symptoms
that could cause comorbidities
for type 2 diabetes,
as well as COVID-19.
So in the middle of the Venn diagram,
between the two conditions,
I've listed immune disruption,
vascular damage, as well
as multiple organ injury.
And these are kind of the
most severe outcomes of both.
But as you can imagine,
the most severe symptoms
of conditions could lead to
the most severe exasperations
in terms of comorbidities.
Okay, so now I kind of wanna pivot a bit
and talk about statistical significance
and significance testing,
which are two techniques that
are used throughout the study.
So first, statistical
significance is basically
a mathematical measurement
of the regularity
of some observed effect.
And then significance
testing are basically
any formal methods that are used
to determine statistical significance.
So, just a quick example
to kind of illustrate
these two concepts.
Let's say that we're
developing some medicine
and we wanna test if this medicine has
the desired effect that we think it does.
So, what we do is we give this medicine
to one group, labelled group 1, here,
and then we get placebo, which we know
definitely does not have
an effect to another group,
which is group 2, here.
And what we wanna do is do an experiment
where we basically compare
the effects of the medicine
on group 1 to group 2,
which we know the placebo isn't
having any effect on them.
So we do this experiment,
and then we collect the data,
and then we put it through
a significance test.
And what a significance test really is,
is just a mathematical
formulation, typically,
where the input is the data that you get
from an experiment.
Okay, and what the
significance test gives you
is what is called a P-value.
And what you can really think
of a P-value is basically
it's a probability that
describes or it's the probability
that the outcome that you
got from your experiment came
about as just pure chance.
So in this case,
from the experiments,
let's say that we got that
the medicine actually did have
like some sort of effect on
group 1 as compared to group 2.
So, this corresponding P-value
we got, which is 0.045,
or 4.5% is basically
saying that the probability
of the outcome that we
got, which is the medicine
actually did have an effect on group 1,
just being coming from
pure chance is very low,
or approximately 0.045 or 4.5%.
And so, given this P-value, we can say
that we're pretty sure that
the results that we got
from this experiment is significant
and then we can say that
we probably think that the medicine
actually definitely does
have a significant effect.
Okay.
So, just a quick poll about P-values
to kind of drive this concept home.
So, the poll states, given
that a P-value represents
the probability that a phenomenon
happens by pure chance,
what P-value would we expect to get
from a significance test
something that most probably
is not a random occurrence?
And the answer choices are, a, 0.9 or 90%,
b, 0.001 or 0.1%,
c, 1 or 100%,
and finally, d, 0.67% or 67%.
Excuse me.
All right, so looks
like most people said B,
which is the correct answer.
And remember this is correct, because
the P-value represents the probability
that a phenomena happens by pure chance.
So if we're testing something
that we know is definitely
not a random occurrence,
we'd want the P-value to be extremely low
because that would tell us that
our intuition about that is correct.
Okay.
So, going back to the keywords.
So, yeah, just keep these keywords in mind
as we move along in our discussion.
So number one is glucose, which remember
is the small sugar molecule
which gives your cells energy.
And then comorbidity, is any condition
whose symptoms can overlap with another's
to exasperate them.
And then lastly, significance test,
which is basically any
formal test of significance,
as well as the P-value,
which is the probability
that the outcome that you
got came from pure chance.
Okay.
So now I'm going to go
into the methodology
that the authors used in this paper.
Excuse me.
So how do the authors approach this issue?
So before we get into the
the exact methodology,
I just wanna mention that
this is what is called
a retrospective, longitudinal
and multicentered study.
So what do these words mean?
So, a retrospective study is any one
that compares two groups of people
where the groups differ by one
or more factors of interest,
and where the data is collected
prior to the analysis.
And then a longitudinal study
it's one where the same
observation basically
is made repeatedly over
a set period of time.
And then a multicentered study is just one
that takes place in multiple settings.
So keep these words in mind
and then I will come back to them
as I talk about the
methodology of the paper.
Okay, so this figure here kind of presents
exactly how the researchers
started their project.
So let's start at the top
of this flow chart up here.
So it says that 9,663 patients
were diagnosed with COVID-19
and we're admitted to 19
hospitals in the Hubei Province
in China, from December
30th to March 20th.
So, this is the initial cohort or group
of people that the
researchers started with.
And what they want to do
with this number of people
is they want to split this
group into two groups,
one being one with patients
that had pre-existing type 2 diabetes,
and then another one that did not.
So, in order to get to these two groups,
the researchers took two or three steps,
where they essentially eliminated patients
who were ineligible for the study.
So for example, they
eliminated 872 patients
that did not have
complete medical records,
and therefore, could not
participate in the study.
Another example, about 1,000 patients
who were under the age of 18
or above 75, were eliminated
and then finally, after
this elimination process,
the researchers got to
this final cohort number
of 7,337 total participants.
Then they split this large group
up into two smaller groups,
one that had 952 participants,
and all of these patients had
pre-existing type 2 diabetes,
and then at the other, which
had 6,385 participants,
and this was the non-type
2 diabetes group.
And by the way, type two diabetes
is abbreviated here as T2D.
Okay, so once the group had
these two cohorts, what they did was
they collected several
variables for all the patients.
So, first they collected each
participant's age and gender.
Second, they collected
each participants symptoms
upon admission, as well as over time.
And then next, they
collected the comorbidities
that were present at admission
other than type two diabetes.
And then they also
collected the blood profiles
of every patient upon
admission as well as over time.
And blood profiles
are basically kind of
like your blood work.
So they were just looking for
things in the patient's blood,
which were relevant to the study.
So for example, they were looking
for glucose concentrations,
or insulin concentrations
and stuff like that.
And lastly, they collected
the overall management
of each patient while admitted.
And what management means is basically
any medical intervention that
any patient had to undergo.
So that could have been
things like administration
of certain medicines, onto the patients
or the use of some medical
instrument like a ventilator.
And, by the way,
just to go back to the
previous three definitions,
this study is first of
all a retrospective,
because we're comparing
two groups here that differ
by some variable that we're interested in.
In this case, it's type 2 diabetes.
And then it's longitudinal
because we're recording
all of these variables
over and over again,
basically over a certain period of time.
And then it's multicentered
because it took place
in 19 different hospitals where
the patients were admitted.
Okay, so going further, the
researchers kind of delineated
the 952 type 2 diabetes patients
further into two groups.
So the first group was, it was labeled
the well-controlled BG Group,
which BG stands for blood glucose.
And in this group, were
patients that had glucose levels
in their blood which were considered to be
in a healthy range.
And here this is considered to be
from 3.9 to 10 millimolar per
liter of glucose in the blood.
And a millimolar per liter is kind of
just a measure of concentration.
And the other group was
the poorly controlled blood glucose group.
And this group had patients who
had what is considered
to be unhealthy levels of
glucose in their blood.
And in this case, that's considered
to be above 10 millimolar per liter
of glucose in their blood.
And then once they had these two groups,
they recorded all the same
variables that I had just talked
about in the same slide for both groups.
Okay, so once the researchers
had all of these variables,
what they did was they compared
all the groups that they
had delineated to each other
on the basis of each variable.
So in this case, the
researchers are comparing
the type 2 diabetes cohort
to the non-type 2 diabetes cohort,
on the basis of medical
management, and in this case,
it's the use of particular drugs.
And in this case they recorded
the frequency with which
each group had to be
administered these drugs.
So once they had all this
data, what they did was
they applied a significance test to it
and then they generated P-values
for each instance of variable.
And I'm just looking at
a more specific example,
we're gonna look at a drug
called systemic corticosteroids,
which is basically a drug that helps
with really severe immune responses.
So, looking at the type 2
diabetes cohort, we can see that
these patients were prescribed this drug
at a rate of about 29.4%
compared to the patients
of the non-type 2 diabetes cohort,
which were prescribed this
drug at a rate of about 23%.
Okay, so, we can clearly see that
the type 2 diabetes patients
were prescribed this drug
at a much higher rate
than we're the non T2D patients.
So now, we wanna establish
significance in this data
and we wanna be able to say that
this isn't happening just by pure chance.
So what the researchers
are doing is they're taking
this data and they're putting
it into a significance test.
And in this case, they
get that the P-value
for this particular case
is actually below 0.001,
or below 0.1%.
And remember, a P-value is the probability
that your outcome came as a
result of just pure chance.
So in this case, that
probability is extremely low,
which means that we can say
that in fact, this outcome
is significant and didn't come about
as a result of pure chance.
And therefore, we can
say that type 2 diabetes,
having type 2 diabetes
and COVID-19 is correlated
with a higher rate
of being prescribed
systemic corticosteroids
to deal with particular symptoms.
Okay, so now we're gonna go
into kind of the results section
and what the authors add to this field.
Okay, so the first major
result of the study
is that type 2 diabetes is in fact
a major comorbidity for COVID-19.
And
here I presented a table where
they present the outcomes,
or the most severe symptoms,
that patients faced.
So in this table, what they're
doing is they're comparing
the type 2 diabetes cohort
to the non-type two diabetes cohort,
on the basis of outcome.
So, from this table, we can
see that for pretty much
every severe kind of outcome,
the type 2 diabetes cohort
are experiencing these
outcomes at a much higher rate.
So if we look at one specific
example, which is ARDS,
which stands for acute
respiratory distress syndrome,
which is basically a really
severe respiratory outcome,
we can see that the type
2 diabetes patients suffer
from this outcome at a
rate of almost 17% compared
to the non type two diabetes patients,
which suffered this outcome
at a rate of just 7%.
And this result, when applied
to a significance test had
a P-value of below 0.1% which again,
means that we can correlate
having type 2 diabetes
with a higher rates of ARDS.
And this is true pretty much
for all of these outcomes,
except this one,
DIC, which stands
for disseminated
intravascular coagulation.
And this had a P-value
of above 0.05.
So we can't really say that this result
is really significant,
but we can't really say
that it's not significant
from the significance test that was done.
And this could probably be due to
just like the low number of people
who actually suffer from this outcome.
But in general,
for the rest of the outcomes,
the results were extremely
significant below 0.1%.
Okay, so the second major
results from the study
was that control of glucose
in the blood is essential
to good outcomes in COVID-19 patients
with pre-existing type two diabetes.
And the first kind of chart
that I'm gonna present
for this results, is a similar
one to the previous one.
So in this case, they are comparing
the well-controlled blood glucose cohort,
to the poorly controlled
blood glucose cohort,
on the basis of medication prescription
for particular outcomes that they had.
So again, for pretty much every
single medical intervention
that's shown in this
chart, we can see that
the poorly controlled
blood glucose patients had
to be administered all
of these interventions
at a much higher rate.
So again, let's look at
systemic corticosteroids.
So looking at the poorly
controlled blood glucose group,
we can see that they are
prescribed this at a rate
of about 35% compared to 20% for
the well-controlled patients.
And this result had a
P-value of less than 0.1%,
which means that this results
was extremely significant.
And this is true pretty
much for all of these drugs.
Some of them don't have the
most significant P-value,
for example, this one
has a P-value of 0.5%,
which means that the probability
of this outcome being
from pure chance is 50%,
which is extremely high.
So we really can't say much about this.
But again, there wasn't
really many prescriptions
of this particular drug,
seven for the poorly controlled group
and then two for the
well-controlled group.
So that really high P-value
could just come down
to not enough people participating
in that particular variable.
Okay, so the next thing
I'm gonna present is
this graph, which I think
really kind of encapsulates
the result that controlled glucose
is really, really important
to good outcomes in COVID-19
and type 2 diabetes patients.
So what this graph
is kind of showing is the
percent survival rates for
the well-controlled cohort patients,
as well as the poorly
controlled cohort patients.
So first to kind of explain the graph,
on the x-axis is given time in days.
So from day zero to day 28.
And then on the y-axis is
given the percent survival
and these numbers are in percents.
So it starts from 100%,
and it goes to 80%.
So, first looking at the
well-controlled cohort,
we can see that over time,
their survival rate kind
of is pretty steady,
it kind of hovers around about 98%,
which is pretty comparable to people
who actually don't have type two diabetes
who also contracts COVID-19.
But then, when we look at
the outcomes for the
poorly controlled cohort,
we can see that over time,
their survival rate actually dips down
really dramatically compared
to the well-controlled cohort.
It dips down to below 95% to about 93%
at day 28.
And this is, I think, the
most significant results
of the study because
it really demonstrates
that even though the poorly
controlled cohort patients
from the last slide, we know that they had
more medical interventions,
than did the well-controlled group.
The well-controlled
group is still surviving
at a much, much higher rate
than the poorly controlled group.
So this kind of implies that
one of the most important things
in good outcomes for COVID patients
with a pre-existing type 2 diabetes
really is just
good control of blood glucose,
and remember, healthy blood
glucose in the study is defined
between three and ten millimolar per liter.
Okay.
So finally, I'm gonna talk a bit about
the conclusions of the study
and the specific limitations,
as well as future studies
for this kind of research.
So first, I'm gonna talk a bit about
the clinical significance of the results.
So this is kind of a cartoon,
actually from the paper itself,
and I think it really presents the
most important clinical outcome
from the study really well.
So it kind of depicts the previous graph
in a kind of cartoonish way.
So the blue line is the survival rates
for the well-controlled
blood glucose cohort group.
And then the red line
represents the survival outcomes
for the poorly controlled
blood glucose patients.
So what this is kind of depicting is
on the blue line, is
kind of a person who is
like battling COVID kind of really well.
And they have a survival rate of 98.9%,
which again, is really
comparable to COVID patients
who don't have type 2 diabetes.
So
and this I think, really demonstrates
the importance of maintaining
good blood glucose
when diagnosed with COVID-19.
And then, in comparison, on
the red poor outcome line,
is a person is depicted
as kind of like falling
as result of COVID-19.
And these individuals have
a death rate of about 11%,
which is really, really
a dramatic decrease
from the 98.9 survival rate of those
who have well-controlled blood glucose.
So again,
the clinical significance here is that
really one of the most important
things in these individuals
who have COVID-19, as well as
pre-existing type 2 diabetes
is really strict control
of their blood glucose.
Okay, so now I'm gonna go
a bit into the limitations
of the study, as well as
some future directions
of this research.
So first, a really good way
that this research could be extended
is through the performance of a similar
what's called a prospective
study, in order to supplement
the current study, which is
again, a retrospective one.
And what a prospective study is,
it's really similar to
retrospective studies,
except that when you're
comparing your two cohorts
that have some variable
that you're interested in,
what you're doing is you
are kind of tracking them
or tracking outcomes, excuse me,
in real time, rather
than working with data
that was previously collected
as in a retrospective study.
Okay, another thing that could be done
is to increase the type
2 diabetes cohort size.
And if you remember, the total cohort size
was approximately 7000 patients,
and then the type two diabetes
cohort size was about 900,
which is really, really
small, obviously, compared
to the total cohort size.
And size of the cohort really matters
in these kinds of analyses,
because the statistics
that the researchers take
advantage of in this case,
really depend heavily on size.
And when comparative size, as
in this case is really small,
we can get a lot of what's
called confounding factors
in our analysis, which are
basically just
factors that we don't
necessarily care about
but are affecting our results.
Okay, so another thing that
we could do is to understand
the comorbidity between COVID-19
and type 2 diabetes at a
more fundamental level.
And what I mean by fundamental is more of
at a kind of basic science level.
So understanding the comorbidity
at like a biochemical level
at a biophysical level, so that
we could potentially create
a really specified specific treatments
for individuals who suffer from
both type 2 diabetes and COVID-19.
And this could manifest
in pharmaceutical treatment,
but it could definitely be something else.
Okay, and the last thing
is to make this study,
to extend the results is to make the study
more multicentered,
and that to perform it
in more diverse communities.
And as I had mentioned previously,
both COVID-19,
as well as type 2 diabetes
affects certain populations
really at a disproportionate rate.
And if you remember
this, the current study
that we're talking about now was done only
in Hubei Province in China.
So performing a really similar study
to this one would really help
in kind of getting better health outcomes
for particular communities
that are affected
disproportionately by both diseases
because these communities
could potentially have
really unique factors that affect them
which don't affect other communities.
So again, just making it
more multicentered, would
really help to impact
the positive health outcomes
that could possibly come
out of this kind of study.
And kind of just to further
that point, I'm gonna present
some data about diabetes
diagnoses in the United States
as delineated by race and ethnicity.
So, if you look on the last three bars
on this bar graph here, you
can see that Hispanic people,
black people, as well as
Native American people
are diagnosed with diabetes,
the most frequently out
of any other race or ethnicity
in the United States.
And then this data kind of
presents something similar
but with COVID-19, so it presents
the percentage of deaths due to COVID-19
as delineated again,
by race and ethnicity.
So from this data, we can see that Black
and African American people,
as well as Spanish and
Latino people make up a 14%,
as well as a 19% respectively.
And this is data from New York State.
So this is their populations
in New York State.
But they actually make up
more than 50% of all total COVID deaths,
despite making a much less than
50% of the total population.
So just taking this
data as well as the data
that I presented in the last
slide, and kind of going back
to why this study is really important,
because obviously, this is
extremely disproportionate.
And, again, both COVID-19
and type 2 diabetes affect
these communities of color
really, disproportionately.
So this kind of study that kind of looks
into the interactions and intersections of
both of these diseases,
which again, affect these communities,
at disproportionate rates
is extremely important
to developing really
positive health outcomes,
as well as just providing better medicine
to these communities.
And again, going back to my
thing about making this
study more multicenter again,
these communities can
really suffer from factors
that are really unique to them,
which create these disproportionalities.
So making this kind of
study more multicentered
and more focused
on these communities
specifically, can really
impact these communities in a positive way
and again, create really,
really amazing health outcomes,
as well as just improve medical treatment
of these communities in general.